SANDEEP GUPTA: Hi.
My name is Sandeep
Gupta, and I'm
a product manager in the
TensorFlow team in Google.
Today, I will talk about
TensorFlow Enterprise
and how it can help you
in building and deploying
your ML workloads with
TensorFlow on GCP.
Machine learning is transforming
every aspect of our lives,
and developers and
enterprises are
using ML to build
impactful solutions that
drive business value.
TensorFlow is one
of the most widely
used production-ready
frameworks for machine learning.
And it's open-source
by Google so
that everyone can take advantage
of these powerful tools.
But if you are an
enterprise trying to use ML,
there are some
challenges you may face.
New TensorFlow open-source
releases come out several times
a year, and you may have
business reasons to stay
on an older version longer.
In this case, you would want
that critical patches, fixes,
and enhancements be available
in these older versions.
Second, Cloud
provides the ability
to build and deploy ML
with the performance
and scalability
that Cloud offers.
This can be difficult,
as it may require
a lot of manual
configuration and setup
to make sure that you'll get the
best out of your infrastructure
investment.
And lastly, you
expect prioritized
and trusted support.
We designed
TensorFlow Enterprise
with the goals of addressing
these types of challenges
when it comes to
enterprise-grade ML.
TensorFlow Enterprise is
the GCP-optimized experience
of TensorFlow.
It consists of
three main pillars.
First is performance
and the ability
to handle cloud-scale
data and models.
TensorFlow Enterprise
includes optimizations
to help you get the most
from your data pipelines
and ML model training on GCP.
Second is manageability.
While solving your
business problem,
you do not want to spend
your time and energy
creating and maintaining
the software environment
and managing all the
machines in your cluster.
You just want to focus
on the code business
logic of your ML problem that
matters to your business.
TensorFlow Enterprise
makes it easier
to build and run ML workloads
with these managed services.
And lastly, TFE releases
come with long-term support,
which provides backporting of
critical patches and fixes.
So we'll look at all three
of these in more detail now.
Let's start by looking at
cloud-scale performance first.
So at TensorFlow Enterprise,
we compile and ship a special
build of TensorFlow, which
is optimized for Google Cloud
infrastructure.
It is built on
open-source TensorFlow,
but it contains add-ons
with additional runtime
optimizations and I/O
optimizations, which
are specific for Google
Cloud machines and services
to help improve performance.
Let's take a look at an example.
So this is a code
snippet that you
can use to train a model with,
potentially, a large training
data set in Google
Cloud Storage.
Cloud storage is
GCP's file storage,
where you might maintain
terabytes of training data.
As you see, this
code snippet is no
different from your typical
TensorFlow code written
with the tf.data API, except
that the path to the files
points to your GCS bucket.
Under the hood,
TensorFlow Enterprise
build contains
optimized I/O readers
to make this performance
with Google Cloud Storage.
Here's another example
where we read our training
data set from a BitQuery table.
BitQuery is GCP's
SQL-based data warehouse,
where you might maintain a
business intelligence data
link with hundreds of millions
of rows in many tables.
And you might want to train
your models from all this data.
Here, we are
specifying the table
to read from, the
columns to read
and their data types, and
several other specifications
similar to the
standard tf.data API.
And we are performing
additional transformations,
such as batching and shuffling.
Under the hood, optimized
I/O for BitQuery
can read many millions
of rows in parallel
into the tensors efficiently.
So with these
optimizations included,
you can get faster throughput
in your model training
with TensorFlow Enterprise.
Here is an example
on a recommendations
data set where we
see that we get
about a 30% higher throughput
with TensorFlow Enterprise
optimizations.
This gain in data throughput
improves the utilization
of accelerators, such as
GPUs, because now, you
are no longer bottlenecked by
I/O. It results in shorter wall
time of training for
the same accuracy,
as shown in the
chart on the left.
The purple graph you see here
is the GPU utilization profile
with TensorFlow Enterprise 1.15
on one model training example.
You'll see that it
is narrower in time,
indicating shorter wall time,
and also attains a higher peak,
indicating higher
peak utilization.
Compared to the orange
graph, with TensorFlow 1.14,
which does not have
these optimizations.
This better I/O throughput helps
reduce the cost of training.
Also, with networking
optimizations to NCCL,
better performance is
achieved when you scale
to large clusters of GPUs.
For example, when training
the BERT Large model
for NLP problems on
a 64 GPU cluster,
we see about a 30% speed up with
these improvements built in.
So we have seen
some optimizations
for better scale and
performance on GCP
in TensorFlow Enterprise.
Now, let's take a look at
how TensorFlow Enterprise
makes it easy to build ML
through managed services.
We deliver TensorFlow Enterprise
through a managed environment.
These are in the form of
deep learning VM images
and deep learning
container images,
where the environment
is pre-configured
on top of a standard Linux
box and made available to you.
What makes this convenient
is that it pre-installs
the TensorFlow Enterprise
build, together
with all the
dependencies, including
device drivers, common
dependency packages,
and configurations to other
services on Google Cloud.
This means that
you no longer have
to think about installing all
the right packages and drivers
with correct
combination of versions
or wrangle with all of
their configurations.
And support for all Google
Compute Engine security
features, such as
customer-managed encryption
keys and VPC, is built
in right out of the box.
Because these are packaged
VM and container images,
you have many choices for
deploying them and using them
on the Cloud.
To get started, you pick
the TensorFlow Enterprise
image and the desired resources,
such as the machine type
and accelerator of choice, and
you start the virtual machine,
all with one line of command.
Then, you can SSH
into the machine that
has TensorFlow Enterprise
installed with all dependencies
and device drivers
reconfigured, and you
can start using TensorFlow.
If you prefer a
notebook environment,
JupyterLab is hosted and
already started on the VM,
so you can go to the
browser and start
writing code in a notebook.
Once you have a
satisfactory model
after running some
experiments, now you
can train your models with the
full scale of your enterprise
data.
It may not fit into
one machine and you
may want to take
advantage of distributed
training for large scale
of data and models.
GCP's AI Platform Training
is a managed service
for serverless
training that takes
care of distributed training
clusters and provisioning
of compute resources.
More importantly, it drives
the same TensorFlow Enterprise
container, which has the
same environment as you have
developed the model with,
so you can be confident
that your model just trains
with the full scale of data
on AI Platform Training.
Here, we see an example
of how to do this.
You create a container, starting
with a TensorFlow Enterprise
base image.
Overlay this with your
model training code.
Then, you issue one command
to start serverless training
on GCP.
In this example, we are using
10 workers for our distributed
training cluster, with eight
V100 GPUs attached to each.
This brings up the
distributed training cluster
with TensorFlow Enterprise
optimizations included.
Very soon, Cloud AI
Platform Training
will use these DFE images
as the default runtime,
so you will not have to import
a DFE container manually,
as shown here.
Now that you trained your
model in full enterprise scale,
it is time to make it
an end-to-end pipeline
to continue running
in production.
This can be done using
GCP's AI Platform
Pipelines, which are built with
TensorFlow Extended, or TFX.
AI Platform Pipelines is hosted
on Google's Kubernetes Engine,
so it can also drive the same
TensorFlow Enterprise container
image, so that all the
optimizations are still
included, and you
can be confident
that your pipeline trains the
same way as your notebook code.
In addition to manage
training and hosted pipelines,
there are other
additions that make
TensorFlow run better on GCP
with TensorFlow Enterprise
add-ons.
Let me show you two examples.
First, TensorFlow
Cloud repository's APIs
allow you to easily go
from debugging and training
your Keras and TensorFlow
code in a local environment
to distributed
training in the cloud.
To use this, simply
add that the TF Cloud
run API call to your
Keras model training code.
It will take care of adding
the right TF distribution
strategy, based on the cluster
configuration that you provide.
And a training job will
be triggered on GCP
using the cloud
AI platform APIs.
Hyperparameter tuning
is an important step
in fine tuning and
optimizing your model.
You can use the KerasTuner
API, conveniently within Keras,
to use hyperparameter tuning
in your model training.
CloudTuner is GCP's
implementation
of the KerasTuner API.
It is fully API-compatible
with KerasTuner
and uses GCP's optimizer
search algorithm under the hood
to run the
hyperparameter tuning.
These add-ons are
part of the standard
build of TensorFlow
enterprise and make
your journey from
offline experimentation
to cloud-scale
implementation easier.
Now that we have seen
cloud-scale performance
and cloud-integrated
managed services,
let's talk about
enterprise-grade support
that comes with
TensorFlow Enterprise.
Key aspect of this
is long-term support.
Open-source TensorFlow comes
with a one-year-of-maintenance
window.
For TensorFlow
Enterprise, we extend that
and commit to providing
three years of support that
includes critical bug
fixes and security badges,
and optionally, backporting
important feature enhancements
from future releases, based
on customer needs and demand.
This means that you
can rest assured
that you can upgrade
TensorFlow versions based
on your business's timelines.
As of today we support
both TensorFlow 1.x and 2.x
with TensorFlow Enterprise
long-term support.
Here's a great example of
what long-term support can
mean for you in practice.
NVIDIA recently launched
their A100 family
of GPUs, which bring significant
performance improvements.
In collaboration with NVIDIA,
we have updated the TensorFlow
Enterprise 1.15 and 2.1
Deep Learning VM images
and added support
for CUDA 11, cuDNN8,
and the new TensorFlow
32 data format
to help your code take advantage
of the A100 architecture.
These TensorFlow
Enterprise versions
are the only official builds
of TensorFlow 1.15 and 2.1
with this support built
in before this lands
in the mainline
open-source releases.
You can become an early
user of these GPUs
on GCP with these
pre-built images.
Getting started is really easy.
With this example
gcloud command line
I've shown here, where we create
a TensorFlow Enterprise 2.1
VM which supports A100 GPUs.
You can learn more about these
GPUs in our cloud accelerator
session.
Before closing, let me
share what lies ahead
for TensorFlow Enterprise.
We are excited to keep working
tightly together between Google
Cloud and the TensorFlow teams.
As being the creators
and experts of both,
we plan to provide further
optimizations and enhancements
to TensorFlow on Google Cloud--
better monitoring and
debugging capabilities
to follow TensorFlow code and
integrations into Google Cloud
tooling.
We are also looking at
smoother integration
between TensorFlow's
high-level APIs,
such as Keras and the
training services,
as well as more managed
services, such as Enterprise
version of tensorboard.dev
and integrated experiment
management and tracking for a
seamless and joyful developer
experience.
I hope I've been
able to show you
how TensorFlow Enterprise
can help your business use
ML and TensorFlow on GCP.
To get started, visit
this link shown here
and check out all the
documentation and resources.
On behalf of the
TensorFlow Enterprise team,
I would like to thank
you for listening.
Thank you.